in this video I let you know about my
new film blog I tell you about an
experiment which I'm running at the
moment and I let you know how I made a
huge mistake in my PhD another one we
have definitely running sound right good
I just recorded an entire video with the
sound off can I didn't tell on the
microphone recording so I'm back here
next to after two weeks away in France
those of you who saw my livestream
advert will see what I got up to when I
was over there
thanks incidentally to everybody who
came and watched that livestream which
is a Thomas Frank and with Jamie Myles
talking about adult life skills and how
to adult it was really really good fun
together I mean admittedly it was what
o'clock in the morning for me and I got
sleep at like half three but it was it
was so much fun to do and I just like to
nice news anyway because I like having
the live interaction with you guys so
hopefully we're gonna try and do this
more regularly like every month or two
if you like the sound of that and
comment below because I would take any
excuse to do more of them because
there's so much fun so in terms of other
content that's gonna be coming out on
this channel between now and Christmas
I've worked at a rough schedule but I'm
not gonna post it because the last time
I did that I got a bit ill from all the
stress so we've got coming up a
crash-course Erie's on my research and
the stratosphere generally and i
realized i've said i've done i would do
this like twice in the past but i was
never completely happy with my setup or
the script or how much time I had now
I'm happy with all those things so
that's gonna be coming up me thinking
about a month's time and that's gonna be
three videos there's also going to be
for me really exciting series which is
going to be talking about the run-up to
the Paris climate talks so these are the
United Nations talks this December
basically trying to hopefully introduce
a cap on emissions now for this series
I'm gonna be interviewing people from
the Met Office and professors from the
climate here in Exeter and clue in on
not just the science of what's going on
but also what we can expect to happen in
these talks how they work and what do
we get absolutely nothing from them
which might happen then there's gonna be
a series after that leading into
December where we're gonna be looking at
double again so you might remember that
I went off to Doral to make some vlogs
for them if you didn't see them then
click over here and this time we're
gonna be looking at the conservation
issues which they face there's gonna be
about three or four videos analyzing the
work they do why they exist and why
they're important and that's going to
lead directly into my project for
awesome video this year which is going
to be about Daryl again and it'd be
really awesome to have you guys
supporting me on that and then as well
as all of those videos there's gonna be
a few standalone ones which you saw one
for example recently which is the p80
video there's going to be a few
individual ones that are not pass'
series as well as these vlogs so it's
quite a help coming out actually I'm
trying to put more effort into this
YouTube channel basically and also other
video projects which I'm not quite ready
to talk to you about yet but it's kids
hopefully this channel is going to
become a lot more I don't know say
seriously
but like there's gonna be a lot more
production put into it basically
unfortunately that means that I've had
to drop some other commitments this year
I'm not gonna be doing any acapella
singing so if you're watching this next
track of power I really miss you guys
but I will be continuing with Chapel
Choir and that's actually the only
extracurricular thing I may be doing
this year apart from YouTube because the
phd's kind of starting to ramp up so
while this week has been fresh as we can
Exeter and I've been doing an awful lot
of singing events and trying to
encourage people to get involved in
societies
I was fundamentally back to work so when
I went back on Monday I got into my
office early in the morning and I was
really really pleased to see that the
program which had written to run wires
away in France had crashed after a day
basically this program was supposed to
generate lots and lots of data which I'm
using in an experiment to effectively
prove or disprove about hypothesis we
have about how mass flows in and out of
the polar stratospheric region now this
data is absolutely necessary there's
really nowhere and get around doing it
but it was going to take a long time to
do is gonna take about 30 days to get a
substantial data set so I programmed it
to run while I was away in France and
then I came back
in a crash so I didn't have their data
and it turns out the reason that it had
crashed was because an old piece of code
which I didn't delete because I'm a
horrible human being that refer to
available which didn't exist anymore
because it was part of an older path
program and it was completely unrelated
to the point the program so I basically
lost a whole bunch of productivity
because of a stupid mistake again
I saw the program running again
immediately though and we have already
actually got some data out of it it
basically saves data at different points
of completion so we have got some data
out and it's looking really good it's
really quite exciting actually I spent
the whole day just playing around with
the output it's actually leading me to
do something which I never done before
in my programming history you had to
remember that I I was never formally
taught how to program I mean I did a
brief course in see you at Oxford but
the whole this whole part of my PhD is
very much new to me and whenever
everyone programs before they've always
been quickly we've always taken second
minutes maybe so I've never had to
bother about optimizing my code and now
I've got a program which literally is
gonna take two months to finish at the
current like rate of completion
so I'm looking into a technique called
paralyzed but parallelization buddy how
it's not not to say they don't do in
order to understand how this works
basically you have to think about the
fact that a modern computer has multiple
processors right which I like multiple
small brains at the moment my program
basically runs through a list of actions
and it does one completes all the tasks
outputs is data done moves on to to does
a lot of stuff after the data and three
then four and each one of those tasks
are completely separate so what the
program carry does is it takes one brain
one processor and it goes one that is it
an output done to that done but there
are three other processes in my computer
so what parallelization does it right
that time is it distributes tasks one
two three four five six seven eight
to those four three other processors
that using all four so in addition to
having one task learning here you have
second task third task four tasks and in
theory it's gonna speed up the rate of
computation by four but um that means to
be seen because I've yet to program it
and it means basically programming
everything again
well not everything I'm being a bit
dramatic but I'm just a bit lazy when it
comes to code as I think basically all
PhD students are if you're a PhD student
and you're not leading to come to code
let me know in the comments because
frankly I think you're a unicorn big
mistake as I though it's actually all
going very well at the moment and it
kind of kind of good timing because its
third year now and I'm starting to write
my thesis at least the background
chapters and it's all getting a little
bit serious so hopefully I'm going to be
vlogging more regularly only doing one
every two weeks maybe and updating you
on my progress and filling you in on the
science of I'm doing hopefully because
well I've now got to keep over reason to
write a program so it's gonna get very
boring very quickly lastly I mentioned
to start the video that I have a new
project I am now running a film blog
called the penitent filmmaker the
penance and filmmaker being me now films
I have like been apart my life and
literally as long as I can remember I've
always loved them and I've always been
fascinated by how they're made I now get
to the point where I have an awful lot
of kit my lights camera action and I'm
dying to make my own short films and I
have to making Ichie videos at some time
now the problem is that what I have seen
an awful lot of thumbs on that I have
there's a lot of our films which I
somehow have missed like really really
famous films and the other day I sat
down to write down a list and I realized
that there about 200 seriously famous
films which somehow just whistles
whistle past me without me noticing so
this film blog the pendants in filmmaker
is all about me watching one of these
films a week and then writing what might
be the most delayed movie review in
history and posting it so two weeks ago
I watched the I watched Forrest Gump for
the first time again I missed it and
then this week the past week I watched a
little mermaid and post the parity so if
you'd like the salad this idea next week
I should be doing pop fiction and then I
think the week after that I actually
don't know maybe King Kong or something
because it's not just films which people
considered to be very popular and it's
very weird that I've not seen die hard
for example they're also films which I
feel like a filmmakers should see like
King Kong cabinet dr. Caligari the third
man so it's gonna be a bit of a mix my
mishmash of the vlog
Blagh stays the same vlog and maybe even
do some new releases so yeah if you like
sound that then follow me on WordPress
share it too you'll fill me friends and
community shouted me for not really
being a very good film lover thanks very
much for watching make sure you leave
down in the comments which videos I'm
most looking forward to on this channel
and also if you have any coding howlers
and massive mistakes which you made
specially for PS new student please let
me know because it will frankly make me
feel an awful lot better I can't
remember what's coming out on the
channel next week but there will be
video and I think there's a blog coming
out in another two weeks look forward
seeing you then thanks for watching
this cover stuff makes me really excited
Lina's this is why I became a PhD
researcher because science like this is
awesome make incremental improvements
I'm doing battle
filter